oh my God you twerps are dead I told you
to leave me and your sister out of your
nerd crap you're saying that there's a
ghost and he wears overalls and he wants
revenge on this town because some kids
in the 80s ruin his crops with their car
races fine fine I'll go check downstairs
to see if there's a goose wait a second
I think I see something guys I think you
were right I think there's actually a
ghost here and I think he wants to kill
us you guys are so freaking gullible now
grow up and play some video games like
normal 8th graders now I'm gonna go
downstairs where I'll probably get
scared by a real life ghost and run away
and make you guys have to deal with it
all by yourselves but you'll learn the
power of friendship